i'm gonna accept a five minute challenge
now
[Music]
against claude
massero apparently from the uk
sounds very french okay i will go
through the
uh what's it called it's called the
anglo-scandinavian i think
because you're playing the scandinavian
against
um against the english
and yeah my opponent is apparently
english i'm playing the english
so what i can say about this opening is
that
it's not good but
not as quite as bad as it looks
which is um often the case actually for
openings where you bring
your queen out early it looks ugly but
it may not be that bad e3
i feel like it's just
a little too soft
and he's not trying to punish me at all
for
my proactive play and this just means
that
apart from my queen which is strangely
placed here
everything else kind of makes sense um
and now that he said he's allowed
uh my h-pawn to run up the board as a
modern chess player
i'm obviously going to be happy with
that
so the current status is i am happy
uh and i think my position is
pretty good
um now i have a choice though
both bishop g4 and h3 look very
attractive
bishop g4 there is queen b3
um knight f3 then followed by castles
there may be some h3
it looks like i should have some tactics
there
okay i'll follow my intuition and think
later
if i shall be required
i'm already seeing tactics like queen b3
knight f3 king to f1 long castles
um by the way after king f1 i do have
h3 but i'm not sure it's
great here i also have h3 and
this time i do think it's very good
though um
those other lines were very very very um
interesting though but i guess we'll
focus on
what has has actually happened
um fg4 looks forced yeah bishop
f um
bishop f1 unfortunately
isn't very good i can go bishop
takes f3
and win the rook as far as i can see
but i have another option which is
a lot more attractive uh
and it's a lot more fun um so i'll take
on c3
the point of this move is just to
uh to free the
the e4 square for for my knight
oh no that's not good you should have
taken the queen
there was no bluff like um
like take the queen what are you
thinking about
um yeah so b c three was obviously the
critical line i would have taken an f3
and then if knight uh king f2 i would
have
um knight to e4 check which is really
really nasty
so we probably or king e2 i have at very
least a
discovery check like knight xh2 and then
take the queen
so i was winning my material back which
is
not as good as winning a rook
um but i had the chance to play a flashy
move and i thought
uh why not especially seeing acid
retained a
massive advantage for me now however um
he's just losing the queen um with
with check and
mate is um is imminent as far as i can
see
um there should be a very quick mate
here let me
treat this as an exercise and try and
find it
okay mate in two
probably there is no mate in two knight
f3
uh king e2
snow mate in two no knight d2 is made
knight d4 is made yeah uh but no no
that i saw uh but knight f3 king d1
knight d4 is not made so there's no
mating one but knight f2 queen e1
is made in in three so okay whatever
we'll go now we'll go for the go for the
maiden three
don't see anything better
so i think for my opponent uh and this
is a very nice mate though
uh which one is the best though
uh knight g1 is also made
the the infamous double check
uh this is cruel but which one do i like
better
i think nah knight knight d4 is still
um it's still nicer because there is a
bit of an echo of
legal mate so i'll go for 94.
okay um the lesson here for my opponent
is
clearly that uh call my bluffs
when i play proactiv provocatively in
the opening
try and punish me i don't always know
what i'm doing
i usually do but not always